[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما هو الشعور ورده الفعل اللي ممكن تسيطر
على تفكيركم وتخطر في بالكم لما تسمعوا
كلمات مثل رغبه قوه نجاح تمكين اكيد شعور
بالخوف والارتباط لانه هذه الكلمات مرتبطه
بالتاثير والتغيير العامه
لكن لو بدي ادقك في المفهوم انه ثابت مش
ممكن انه يساعدني ولا يحفزني اني احدث
تغيير وفرق في حياتك ولو بدي استسلم انه
نجاحي محدود ومقطر ضمن هذا المصطلح اذا
انا فقدت القدره على امتلاك اشاره التحديث
اللي بنشانها انها تسري وتغني حياتي على
الصعيد الشخصي
فكانت كلمه النجاح من ناحيه غامضه لانه
بتدور حواليها كلمات كثير كبيره مثل
التصميم الاراده التفوق المعرفه
الثانيه هي كانت كلمه مغريه تستخدمها بعض
الشركات والبنوك في اعلاناته
فكنت اخاف من نجاح مستهلك نجاح ما بيعرفني
ولا بيشبهني لانه النجاح اللي بتنتجه
المجتمعات وبتتفق عليه وبيمر بسهوله
بالذاكره بجمله عاديه كثير بخوف
عشان هيك انا كنت ابحث عن نجاح بيسمعني مش
انا اللي بصنعوه
مش ممكن انك تستعد وتتحضر له
فاكتشفت ان الشعور بالذات
وبالامتلاء التوعوي
ينبثق بالاساس من الخروج عن الصوره
النمطيه لربه البيت
والاقتناع المطلق انه احنا كربات بيوت
قادرات على احداث التميز والاختلاف الي ما
اله علاقه
انها تكون اعجوبه
لكن
هذا لا يتاثر ولا يمكن ان يتحقق الا اذا
امتلكنا الادوات
والاستراتيجيات الصحيحه الي بتحفز وبتصنع
النجاح واهم اداء ممكن انها تتعلمها ربه
البيت هو فن الخطابه وقوه الكلمه وجودتها
[موسيقى]
شو يعني فن الخطابه
الخطابه هو الاسلوب
من خلال مهارات خاصه
عشان امتلك الكلمه القويه احرف قصيره
عن طريق القراءه
مفاتيح اليوم وبكره واشارات الامان فاكبر
نجاح وتمكين لالها هو التمكين المعرفيه
والثقافي
المراه المثقفه والقارئه بتصير قادره على
انها تصنع حوار مع اي شخص ممكن انها تختلف
معه بوجهات النظر لانها بتوصل لدرجه من
البحر
من التحليل والتركيز والعمل المستمر على
رفع مستوى الوعي العقلي لديها ما يؤدي
بالنهايه الى رفع كفائتها وصقر شخصيتها
المراه لما تقرا
بتصير اكثر حكمه اكثر توازن بتكون قادره
على انها تصويب السلوكيات الخاطئه وبتقوم
بدورها الحضاري والاجتماعي و صنع القرار
لانه اي قرار لها بيكون نافع عن وعي
وتفكير وبعد رؤيه للجوانب الايجابيه من
الامور
بتتحسن نوعيه حياتها
وجودتها وممكن تتفوق على نفسها وتكون نسخه
افضل من ذاتها
واكثر شخصيه مشهوره في العالم كانت تعليم
والتثقيف الذاتي والقراءه له دور في انه
ينقل حياتنا نقل نوعيه من الفقر والبؤس
والادمان على المخدرات
لانها تصير اكثر شخصيه مؤثره وغنيه في
العالم هي اوبرا وينفريه
باطلاق نادي اوبرا الثاني للقراءه واللي
هي بتختار كل شهر كتاب لا تناقشه معجونها
الكلمه القويه
والمعرفه والقراءه هي السلاح اللي بتخلينا
نخلق الفرص من حقوق النجاح
فرصتي انا كانت عام 2018
هناك تعلمت ان التمكين المعرفه والثقافي
قادر على انه يغير الواقع من الاستهلاك
للانتاج من التفاعل الفاعليه من انك تعتمد
على الاخرين للاعتماد على النفس من
التبعيه لاخذ زمام المبادره والقياده
واعتقد هذا ما كان يقصده فولتير
في مقوله له سؤال
من الذي سيقود الجنس البشري
فاجرت الذين يعرفون كيف يقراون
فكانت هذه الفرصه مبادرتي
والنجاح اللي صنعاني
عيد اكتشف ذاته
الاساسي في كل القرارات الي باخذها في
حياتك
وصرت قادره اميز بين القرار
من الذات والعائد لالي وبين القرار اللي
ممكن اي شخص في اي بي او محيطه فيه انه
ياخذه ويؤثر علي
لما قراءه
وزادت خبرتي والتسعه بمعرفتك
وصرت قادره اني اتجوز اي عقبه واي مشكله
في حياته
لاني صرت اكثر ذكاء واكثر قابليه
انه التوحد مرض العصر وانه منتشر بين كثير
من الاولاد سواء في العالم العربي او
العالم
وما استسلمت انه حاله بنتي صعب علاجها
والتغطيها بل درست التوحد دراسه ذاتيه
وقرات كثير من المقالات الاطباء عرب وهير
عرب بخصوص هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]
الاساليب النفسيه اللي ممكن استخدمها مع
بنتي واللي ممكن انها تحسن حالتها
بقدر احكي لكم اليوم
انا قدرت انقل بنتي نقله نوعيه من مرحله
كانت فيها غير قادره على نطق حرف واحد على
الاطلاق مرحله
صار عندها اسلوبها الخاص
صار عندها اسلوبها الخاص في انها تعبر عن
حالها وعن قبولها ورفضها لاي موضوع ممكن
اي حدا يناقشها فيك
بعد سنه
عندها الادراك تضحك المفاهيم
والقراءه احدثت علامه فارق في حياتها
انتبهت لقدراتها وامكانياتها اليوم بنتي
باللغه الروسيه بنسبه 30%
نعم انا ربه لكن هذا لا يعني انا مصابه
بالقصور
انا عندي من القوه
اللي خلوني غير مسار حياتي مش اصحيحه
وعندي اراده مكنتني اني اوقف اليوم امامكم
على منصه مؤثره
لكل نساء الوطن العربي والعالم
النجاح والوصول والفاعليه لا تتم صياغتها
وهيكلتها بناء على مسماك الوظيفه او دورك
العائله او الاجتماعيه
في مرحله واحده فقط
وانما هو عباره عن مرحله تنامي مستمر
ناتجه عن رؤى وخطط سابقه بتخليك منفرده
بخصائص ذاتيه بتمكنك انك تكوني قائده
وتخلقي حياه في اي مجتمع
لكل المشاركات
والحاضرات ربات البيوت
والحضور الكرام
تمرين بسيط
خلينا نحط ايدينا على صدورنا
ان غمض عيوننا
ونفكر للحظه
شو هو الكتاب اللي انا راح اقراه واللي
يغير من حياته
شكرا جزيلا
شكرا